Good
evening. We are back
live.
Hi. I have some experiments to set up
and then if Gabe is around, we're going
to review his code. Then the only other
thing I want to check
Okay, so this container did get a bit
bigger. This is a 12 gig
container. So I don't know where the
extra seven is coming
from. I'll figure that
out. I'll focus on that.
God. Got to actually get my protein in
though for once.
You go just go check if there's an
expiration date on that stuff real
awful. I will uh have to
find a way to
get some more
attempting to learn
Neoim, my
guy. Literally
that. Type Vim tutor into console. Done.
You'll be good in 10 minutes.
It's not that freaking hard.
Like, it's a pretty small set of
keyboard shortcuts that you need to make
it dramatically better than uh, you
know, your normal
editor. And it just takes, you know,
within a week it'll be pretty natural.
did not learn to type. Nah, my guy.
That's not a freaking excuse. All right.
I had three like it literally like
they'd have to get they had to give me
like three hours of test um before they
actually like timed the tests when I was
growing up because I how slow I freaking
wrote. All right. I typed and I typed at
like 8 WPM until I played a [ __ ] ton of
MMOs and now I can actually type like
90. You'll be
fine. The only thing that I do wrong
now, which is I think a lot of
programmers do, my hands are like one
position over to the left of where they
should be because uh it's actually
because of Vim because HJKL.
So, usually you should have your hands
on like um was it JKL semicolon and then
ASDF or whatever, but I'm like one over
to the left because you know constant
shift and mod keys and uh
HJKL. Oh, here's
Gabe. Hey,
Gabe. Doing
well. I uh I'm on stream. I hope you
don't mind. But uh code review time.
Welcome,
We can't hear him, by the way. My bad.
Let me fix
Say something. What do you Oh, wait. No,
it should work.
now. All right, let's take a look at
these
this?
Okay. Submit like really weird tiny PRs.
So let's see this PR different ghost
behavior for each ghost based on
original
world. Yeah, I I put that in there cuz
it's Yeah, it's like a lot of everything
moves. Yeah, should be faster
simulation. It
cool. Ghost all move in a direction that
leads them to closest to their target
tile. Targets are calculated differently
for each
ghost. Ghost cannot turn around in
this scatter. They go to their
corner. Panic. Use random
directions and scatter alternate on a
fixed time
interval. Good model with randomized
starting
position. But we'll get you a good model
then as well. Sweet. I'm excited to see
it.
That should be cool.
Uh, right. There 28 file changes, but if
I recall, it's just a bunch of tidy
little assets.
Yeah, a lot of it's pictures, I
M is
1024. Go up on this. I'm
sure you have a bunch of args. All fine.
You've got a correct looking
logs. We could probably add more to the
logs. Now that I think about it, I think
we'll solve
at the end. It's human playable. It
looks
Yeah. So that that's for the visual
interpolation.
I haven't done it that way. I don't know
if this works on web. It might. Um
I've done it before where I just pick a
number of I just pick a number of
substeps and then I just run
um I run what is this? If step
while Yeah. Okay, I see.
this reverse while time greater than
equal
to okay logic a little odd here but
that's whatever perf test and then we'll
do the main file last
obviously
got params and params in
OBS
counts. OBS are float 32. We'll see what
those are.
Yeah, I'm not sure about the way I did
the observations. I feel like that might
be We'll check. Yeah. And we have veinet
obserations.
arcs. This all looks fine. And these are
all assets, which could have been in a
sprite sheet, but Oh, it's okay. They're
tiny either
way. These aren't a Pac-Man file.
Cool. So, now look at
this big uh file. 959 lines.
which for
Pac-Man I have to see what the ghost
logic looks like. That could be a
reasonable amount of code for
this vector. What is this?
That's a new type, I think.
Maybe it's actually kind of a while
since I wrote this code. It's not
defined anywhere. So, I assume is it
from Raleigh?
Maybe. I don't think so
though. I think it might just be defined
below.
But that you can't do that and see.
Oh, wait. You can because it's a macro.
Yeah, I think that's it. That still
might not be ideal, though. Okay. So,
yeah,
vector language do you get that
convention from?
Type defract. No, the like prefixing
like I vector
Huh.
Um, I think that was to distinguish from
Rayb has a vector too. And I think I
wanted to distinguish this as a integer
vector.
I very rarely make a pause vector, but
let me see how many positions have
um enums got logs. Fine.
That's for the map specifically. This is
for loading the map, I would imagine.
Right. Yeah. Which there's only one map
hardcoded right now, but it's just a
string. So, you could very easily have
more maps
and it's just a char array. So, yeah,
actually, this is totally fine.
Yeah, it would it would be cool if there
was a way to select from multiple maps.
It could be kind of interesting. I now
see I kind of see now why you have why
you made a VC
2. I would have just called it pause if
it's if
um uh if it's not used for anything
else. That's fine. So, we have
direction.
Do you want me to nitpick the hell out
of this or you mainly looking for like
the RL side of stuff?
Go for nitpick it. Why not? I mean, it's
your your project. Well, I mean, it
depends, right? Like I don't know your
programming background. I don't know if
you're looking for like general like how
do I make this code better or you're
looking for like how do I make this like
awesome for RL more, right? It depends.
Um, I mean, I'm I'm open to all
feedback. Uh,
the feedback I give you is not
necessarily going to be true and correct
as much as it's like this is the way I
do [ __ ] and it tends to work very well.
Um, let's see. I I'm very much a like
onein room sort of person, right? So,
it's like I want I want to follow the
conventions of the space I'm in. Well,
nothing here is nothing here is bad yet.
So, let's let me keep looking and seeing
if I see any patterns.
Um, Pac-Man
mstruct the forward declaration. I put
all the strus at the top now, but I
started doing that relatively well very
very recently and it was only because I
started needing a whole bunch of them in
here. This is fine. You got your log
float ops
actions reports. Okay.
or constants, but they're set from
Python, so that's
fine. Uh, this I definitely don't
do. Um, this is a grid, right?
That is actually not a grid. Not a grid.
Okay. Interesting. So the the game map
is a grid, but the tile the dots is
[Music]
a it's a array of pointers to where the
dots are on the map. Um
make a grid
because the dots are at like known
positions. Um so like to reset the map,
all you have to do is reset the dots.
like you don't have to go through the
whole map again. Well, you could just
you could have it literally be one me
copy operation, right?
So often what we'll do to reset maps,
let's say we have a grid and we have
some initial state mem copy, right? You
just save like original
map. That's super fast.
Yeah, that makes sense. especially
compared to like looping through and
doing like pointer stuff.
I generally try to avoid um like double
pointers if at all I can get away with
it just because it's like extra stuff
that can go wrong. We tend to do like
flat, you know, flat arrays whenever we
possibly can. That's fair.
file. Oh, okay. This is just like put up
here for whatever. Okay. Then we have
game map. You do have a game map.
Yes, it's like it's a list of specific
places in the game map. I I don't know.
I This could totally just be a tile
star. You don't have to edit it. I'm
just giving you like feedback for stuff
if you like. I'm also happy with you
like taking your input and doing other
RL things. But like yeah, I would I
would have definitely just made this
like game map. All right. And then I
would do like a rig game map or
whatever. And then it's just a mem copy
to reset. And you save all the looping.
Mhm.
So like this. And then when you need to
reset, you wouldn't even have to do it.
It' just be one mem
copy. A is
fine. Initialized is fine. This is going
to be uh this is going to be C close the
new API.
Gotcha.
And reallocate is
good. And what do we have? Ve
to back to
dispar getting like almost kind of Java
vibes.
Oh, I feel seen. That's
Did you do some Java? I that's kind of
where a lot of my background is. Yeah.
Not that I like I'm sorry, but yeah, I
honestly I Java was like my first main
language, too. I honestly think that
having to do stuff in Java makes you a
worse programmer just like for having to
deal with that
language. It's like, and the reason is
it's like it's so overly abstracted. It
just like creates clutter everywhere.
Um, I mean there's nothing like super
bad yet, but like I get the vibe already
just from having like a ton of these
like short little tiny
methods. We'll
see. We'll see if you like here. The
only time that this would be bad is like
if you use this like three times or
something. Other than that, it's like
whatever. All right. Okay, ve two
distance
squared. Poor Western here is uh you
know high school and was I assume also
subjected to
it. The only thing good about Java is
you can write Minecraft mods in
wrapped pile
at. Okay, this one is fine. I actually I
end up having one of these as
direction.
Okay. Compute ghost
ops. This is correctly normalized. This
is correctly normalized. Provided those
are floats.
Yes.
Are the positions floats?
Um, no. I think everything is an integer
up until this point. That cast
correctly.
I actually don't know. Let me
see. I think I've checked the output
before,
but could be good to double check.
works. Okay, so they're both float.
Good.
Yeah, I don't either. This is also a
well I remember which ones to be careful
about though, right? Yeah. Like if you
didn't have float in front of map with
it definitely wouldn't be a float when
you divide it. Yeah. So
I it makes sense it gets promoted to a
float. I just could have been other way.
This I don't think has to be cast
because I think this will just get
implicitly cast because the ops is a
float. Um that makes sense. And then not
frightened and not
Oh, wait. This is ghost observations.
Yeah. So that's per ghost. So this is
what the ghosts see or you see the
ghost. You see the ghosts. So the ghosts
aren't agents. Those are hardcoded.
Technically, they could be. That would
be kind of funny. It would be. I feel
like ghost would be a little OP if they
were smarter. Like Yeah. I think that
you just You couldn't win the game,
right? Yeah. Four versus
one. Maybe you could do one ghost versus
one agent and it would be more even.
I am questioning whether this array
observation is the right approach at
all or if a grid view would be better
view I would say. Yeah,
I would the same as I've done every
other M and I just give it an 11 by 11
crop tiles around it.
I can do that. I mean, I don't even
know. I don't know how good that is,
frankly, because like you kind of want
to be able to see the ghost from a
little farther away.
But let me see. So, you have the ghost
direction. Uh, you get the ghost
position to be
fair. If you're going to do ghost
position, I would consider doing ghost
relative position.
Mhm.
I think I did try that at some point.
kind of went back and forth.
Wait, wait, wait, wait. Ghost
observations this
offset player observation count
presumably is 11.
Yes, should be.
Yes.
Unless I've made a silly
there. Yeah, you definitely are making
this hard on
yourself. I do such stupid things, but
they're like so simple. But one of the
things I did as well, you have a
separate ghost struck, don't you? Versus
player. Yes. Yep. So, one of the things
that I will often do is I'll just make
like an
entity. It's like, wait, but but what
about, you know, the player can't be
frightened and the player can't it
doesn't matter. Just ignore those
attributes cuz then you can put all the
damn things in one strct.
You can put a you can just like put like
you just have like, you know, entity
star entities. don't have to keep track
of stuff like easy to zero the whole
thing, stuff like
Um, no. Then what's reset round? Is it?
Oh, is this different from C reset?
I don't think so. That really should be
reset episode.
I could understand this if you had
lives.
We could we could have lives. We could
add that. But there's I don't really
care if you have them or not. It's just
if you don't then I would see stuff.
Okay. Now the entire entire field of R
is lucky. GPU and GPU are bottlenecked.
RAM typically
isn't. To be fair, we could make our
stuff way more memory efficient. It's
just like you don't have
to. Memory is the thing we just usually
don't care about. We try to write our
code fast and we do it like stupid on
the memory
side. What's this reset ghost thing do?
I guess it just moves it to it starting
position. Yeah, the way that you've done
it is perfectly sane. Uh, in some sense,
the way I would have done it is a little
less sane. I would have just had like an
array of ghosts or whatever or an array
of even entities and I would have just
had indices like you know pinky is zero
this is one this is two and then just
loop and stuff
that makes sense
the way I do things you'll see like
you'll notice like far fewer like small
like small functions like doing stuff
and generally the code is
like things are less decoupled I would
say but also more succinct.
I definitely agree with you about too
much abstraction being a bad thing
sometimes.
I really try to keep stuff just super
super simple. Yeah. No, I'm I'm with
you.
um the sort of abstractions you see
in a lot of software can get can get
crazy and like a lot of it doesn't serve
a good
purpose. Well, I mean, I like to like
look point to the neural MMO code and be
like, "Okay, look how brain dead simple
that is."
Like, what are these things doing for
you if like I can just literally hack a
like 2,800 line end vout that's better
than anything I did in my PhD that's
arguably one of the most complex RLNs
out there that runs in a million and a
half steps per second and like a
freshman undergrad can read it.
Right. Wait, wait, wait. What are we
doing here? So, hang on. Reset. Oh, yep.
So, that actually does scan through the
whole map,
but then you have a
Huh? Because you just don't have the
spawn.
Okay.
actually Yeah, feel like that's that is
a little bit funky now that I see it
again. The reset
round because a lot of that stuff I'm
doing you would only need to do
once. Like you could avoid doing that in
a reset. I
think it's like I'm putting a spawn
position on the ghost. Why don't I just
set them to their spawn position? Yeah,
they already have they would already
have it.
My initial guess just like like just
like random guess of like how many lines
do I think Pac-Man would be? like 600
700 and I think that's probably about
how short I could make it. Um, just
fiddling with
things. So, it's like so far everything
makes sense. I could definitely see
places to make it more
succinct, but I'm not like what the heck
is this at anything.
So Blinky targets the player.
Yep. Pinky the most direct
targets. There's a lead. So it tries to
go to where it thinks the player's
going.
Yes. Okay.
And then this one
has just a different lead.
That's the most confusing one.
Um, and it's like that in the original
game. Um, there's a lead, but then it
incorporates Blinky's
position over that lead.
Um, it's pretty weird, but that's that's
how it
works. And then glide is
just it targets the player if it's far
away, but then if you're close to the
player, it goes back to its corner.
that might be a little funky. Well, the
thing that's funky about it is
like if you have a grid, you may as well
use it.
Yeah, the the grid is not used as much
as it could be. It
definitely made much simpler.
Yeah.
Have you looked at like some of the the
logic in MOA?
Nope. So, that thing runs I don't know
at least several hundred thousand steps
per second. So, that thing has path
finding for all of the creeps. If you've
ever played League or Dota, all the
creeps have to have pathfinding, right?
Um it has
uh five scripted opponent agents and it
has your five on your team with all the
things that they're doing um in like a
mixed continuous distribute grid and
it's still like it's still really
fast. So some of the techniques in there
are kind of cool.
Nice. The the nice thing about Pac-Man
is like you don't even really need real
pathf finding.
Like the g the map is such that if you
just always move towards the target,
you'll get there. Like there's no
there's nothing to get stuck on.
Yeah. Well, in my case, we did a we
premputed all the pathing in MOA.
Mhm. So, it's a 128x 128 grid, which
means you need a 128x 128x 128 by 128
cache of
Yeah, I would have definitely used the
grid more and I would have definitely
had um like an entity array that contain
uh the ghost and maybe even the
player. I think with those two things,
you'd cut at least like 150 lines off.
Oh, actually I said 600
650 and we are there. Uh we're actually
that's where we are now. Um and this is
just rendering.
We might still be able to cut some stuff
off though. I think you're right. I
still think you could actually I might
have overshot then because I think you
could cut 100 or 150 lines off.
I can take a look at some of the
suggestions.
Wait,
what?
Oh, well, this is crazy. This is Wait,
is
this No, it's not
oneelined. Oh, it's just really long.
Okay, that's not as That's
Okay. I just I got confused about what
it is.
So far, the only two style things I'd
actually ask you to do would be four
space it and then um like
cut like giant signatures at some
reasonable length, tab them in. Okay.
But I'm what I'm going to do is I'm
going to merge it anyways so that we can
uh mess with the mess with this and see
if we can get your stuff training
better.
Oh, you then
um possibly can clean up PR if you have
the time.
Yeah, I think I will.
Long long weekend, do you? I'll just be
grinding on the release.
Okay. And this would be like where you'd
have a texture atlas, but then you'd
still have to have a bigger array of
offsets
potentially. Those colors might be
unused now that I look at them again.
That might be old.
Holy. What are we doing here with the
chefs?
Uh, I'm actually kind of proud of this.
This is how the map's drawn.
Let me see. Um, his wall.
That's how it does the corner tiles.
Really?
Oh, okay. Yeah, that is good. I've had
to do this before. It is not
fun. So,
um, the worst freaking thing I've I had
to do for this actually goes up right
here at the neural MMO. See the map? You
have all the the terrain merges together
and the tiles are lurped as well.
Yeah, it looks great. This is the same
sort of a thing,
right, where like you have to like do
this horrendous tile
mapping and it ends up being like
um it's just like a table lookup, but
populating that table's a pain because
it's like it's it's a full bite. It's
like 256 possibilities or whatever is
just how the math works out because you
have your center tile which is always
you or whatever and then it's like
everything else has options. So it's
eight other tiles that can be zero or
one. There's literally 256
possibilities and coming up with that
table just
sucks. Yeah, good job. I know that that
I know that logic for drawing those
things freaking sucks. Yeah. And you've
got more tile types. Wait, I've got like
very futile types, but still has to
handle the corners. I got to ask. You
couldn't have gotten a static map for
this.
Yeah. No, that could be static. My
reasoning was that the compiler would
sort of compile like not the compiler
would pre-calculate all those constants.
Oh, yeah. No, it's not it's not that
it's slow. It's my uh I mean it's it's
about the fact that you had to put
yourself through writing it.
That's true. I I mean was like if you're
going to do man if you're going to do
this if you're going to go to the effort
of doing uh procedural rendering like
this you may as well have like Pac-Man
on like whatever map ever, right? Yeah.
No, that that could that could be
supported. Yeah. Like that's the only
reason I would ever bother putting in
the effort to do something like this
because this type of thing this is the
type of thing where I would like I'd get
stuck at this and like have a dumb look
at on my face for like several hours.
Yeah. No, I think it would be you could
make a map generator for this very
easily and it would still look like
Pac-Man and that that could be a cool
future project.
I mean, you could do
like I mean, technically, right? Like,
uh there's no reason you couldn't make
full screen just massive Pac-Man where
it's kind of like my big snake sim or
whatever except for Pac-Man and like
it's kind of interesting because it's
it's more specifically adverse aerial.
Mhm. You could actually totally make
like a Pac-Man
themed like ghost like ghost and agent
are both trained and that would actually
be really freaking cool. That would be
super cool.
I think like something kind of funny
about Pac-Man is like even if there
aren't any ghosts, if you're also
optimizing for how quickly it can
collect everything, you've got a
traveling salesman problem. Um, so it's
like still like getting it like optimal
optimal is still kind of
computationally complex. Yeah. To get it
fully optimal, but like hang on. Oh,
well, have you seen the new uh the new
end for the docs?
No. Oh, hang on.
Just wanted to show you the um the new
train because it's really freaking
cool. And it kind of has like a similar
like pathfinding vibe.
screen file.
Let me show you this real quick and then
we're going to get Pac-Man
this. Okay, so this is the new
enders have to get stars.
It's um you know ridiculous
advertising, but this is random
behavior. All right.
Mhm.
cr 4 million steps a second at peak.
So 20 30 seconds for 100 million steps.
the
small uh small
MLP
LSTM but actually they do have memory.
Very nice.
Okay, so this is already done training.
doing a little extra ebel.
They're doing it.
So yeah, that's how multi-agent path
finding goes with RL.
That's interesting. That might kind of
make Yeah, interesting pattern.
It's pretty mesmerizing.
It is. Yeah. You can see that
they're forming like almost like little
schools. Yeah. like because they they
wouldn't want to all go after the same
star because then what what if another
star pops up on the other side.
I I definitely want to make like bigger
versions of like swarming sims at some
point when I have the time. I made this
in a day. Like this was this was for
um uh the new uh new tutorials. So like
this is going to be the multi-ent
tutorial and so it's just it's really
simple. It's very cleanly commented.
It's very very easy code. Uh, and it's
like a good reference now.
Yeah, that's still that's still
interesting behavior. This whole it's
lines and see the way that I have it set
up now. Uh, this number of comments is
just because of the tutorial
But yeah, you can kind of see
the minimum of abstraction. Actually,
look, I did have I did make a position
strct. I made a goal strct here.
I guess I did allow myself one. Well, I
I can rename the position struck to
position to you. I'll probably No, it's
fine. I I don't really care about any
individual thing. I do try to show
people like the the less you abstract,
the better things turn out usually.
Let's get this merged, though. Let's I'm
being pedantic.
There's no ind there's no individual
thing here where I go like that's bad.
Um there's like you know overall
probably could use the grid more
probably could have made like an entity
array and like made it simpler or
whatever but there's no individual thing
that's bad. It's just like a level or
two above you know where it could
be. Let's do
that. Let's emerge this and let's see if
I can help you with training.
drive million warnings, right?
So, this needs a C close. Let me fix
that.
Um. Huh. Oh yeah. This back got
changed. Okay. So, we are at 1.3 million
straining when the starting position was
at random.
But that was really three months ago
when I had it training.
And I think I was using some pretty
different
hypers. 2 mil. That actually made it
slower, which is
unusual. Oh, en at
46%. The M the M speed. Nada.
H. You would think that this would be
fast.
You would. Yeah.
Distraction will get you. I guarantee
you it's the the iteration through the
um the iteration through the dots.
But we'll let you cheat a little bit for
now.
course that's double buffered on eight
course. I keep what I'm doing wrong.
Eight M's, eight
workers. 8192 total
M. There you go. 2 million steps per
second
Well, let's let this train and then
let's see what it
does. I want to see if the way it's
playing it looks like it's doing
something or not.
Well,
there's your problem.
Yeah, that's all right.
Okay. So, it's bugged and uh it found a
way to exploit it cuz look at all the
dots disappearing instantly.
Huh. Um
try your build.
It looked like they were the agent was
still moving. just the graphic like the
visual wasn't updating.
fine. Come here, you tasty ghost. Wait,
aren't you supposed to be faster than
the ghost when you eat a pill?
I didn't really know how to do that with
tilebased movement.
Oh, well then you're never going to eat
him.
It's definitely harder to
I mean if they move out of the way just
in time, right? Look, I can't get Oh, he
just Well, if he's going to be stupid,
then I can. Yeah, they move randomly
when they're they're scattering.
I can't beat this thing, can I? It's
like really freaking hard to beat it
when they are like that. Uh and other
stuff. Yeah. No, that's that's the
starting delay.
Well, I mean, there was definitely with
the eval, right? Let's see. That didn't
look like this. Yeah, that looked like
some sort of bug. Let's see if it's just
if the Let's see if the policies learn
to glitch it or not.
If I just do like this,
you know what that might be? That might
be my interpolation logic
glitched. Like maybe the it's not
interpolating. So the positions never
change.
Seem to
be. Let me check. Let's go through the
checklist.
Let's see if we can't get you a super
awesome Pac-Man
agent. We should 100% be able to train
an agent that is better at this game
than I am.
I think you might be right about making
the ghost slower too or like it's when
they it is when they are supposed to be
slower when they um
uh when Yeah. when they're like Yeah.
powerp
or
whatever. And the way that you do it,
it's you look at the MOA. Um the MOA has
a really nice system. We use the same
sort of thing for GPU drive. It's a
really good system. So, you have a grid.
Your agent's on a grid, but the agent
also has a continuous position. You just
move it on the grid when it crosses tile
bounds. It's really easy to render. It's
ridiculously fast because you just have
to check tiles, right? Especially if
only one thing can occupy a
tile. It's like incredibly easy to work
with. Pretty good overall.
thoughts. Bro is a hacker.
We're hacking some
Pac-Man. Let me go get my hoodie and
sunglasses cuz everyone codes in
that. This is OBS count plus ghost times
num ghost. Let's stop.
That looks fun.
You know, almost seems like as if the
action isn't being updated because it
just moves down during the eval. Looking
at it, the single action space ought to
be in
32. Our
actions
Right.
Uhoh. Gotcha.
gotcha. Well, your animation isn't being
updated here either, but it's actually
moving around now. Yep. Why does the
animation not get updated? Is it because
of that frame time thing? I wonder. I
think it's got to be. Yeah. So, I fixed
your end. Um, you see this has to float
to your int.
Yep.
Got him.
You know why I found it that quickly?
Cuz I did the same bloody thing
yesterday.
Oh, that's a little bit better, don't
you think? That's a whole lot better.
What's max score?
Should be the number of
tiles plus Let me Let me double check.
It's the number of tiles plus the number
of power ups.
But the power ups got a bonus bonus
points for those. I think five points
per power up and there's four.
That doesn't track because it's over
that. It is over that. You get points
for ghost.
Yes, you do get points for ghosts. I
would add like a powerup seat and then
ghost seat. Add a couple stats.
That still seems like that might not
track. Like that might be too high. I'm
not sure. Let's see how good the agent
is, though. But we're not going to be
able to tell until I fix that evil thing
on you. Uh we'll see if the dots go away
at
least. The goal definitely is get all
the dots. I would consider that a solve.
So if we do that out of the
box, you have not gotten this thing to
solve out of like to solve, have you?
I have but not with the random starting
position and by default it's not random.
This would be first thing we tried which
I think will be to great credit of the
uh the new algorithm because there's no
way this would have worked in in 20.
Okay,
we kind of have like a ridiculously good
reinforcement learning algorithm now for
what it is. Nice. Um this it has soded
out of the box two different client
ends.
Nice. That's awesome.
There's anyone on YouTube here watching
is in industry wants their reinforcement
learning to actually work. Let me
know. We make it easy.
Huh? Oh, it's get it's going. That looks
good. Okay, so the score is the score is
completely different then from what cuz
it's getting 200 something
which is definitely not bad. Like that's
way better than random.
Oh, this is about as well as I was
doing, I think.
So the question is why is there a
discrepancy between this score
number what's being
logged? Oh it you can see it's eating
ghosts. Does their animations change to
eaten? Yep.
Uh it starting position is not being
randomized.
No, by default it's not. How do we do
that? There is an option to do that. Um
go in the trainer there. It should be
one of the things passed in from the
Python side.
Randomized starting. Yep. That's for the
player.
does that need to be energy. Yeah. I'm
going to try it like this if you don't
mind. That looks still just about Well,
no, the score is lower, but it's going
up. Well, to be fair, you like there are
way more really bad starting positions,
I think, than like really good ones. If
you start near the ghost, you're just
screwed.
Ghosts definitely need to move a bit
slower when uh after you've eaten the
pills or I don't think the game is
solvable otherwise.
Yeah, it might not be solvable all the
time at least.
does. It's definitely harder than actual
Pac-Man if they don't slow
down. It's actually kind of insane how
well this is working.
Um, I don't know how long you've been
around reinforcement learning. This is
not a thing that existed a few months
ago.
like to have a new environment of any
substantial complexity just like get
something reasonable on the first
training run is not a thing that used to
happen. Yeah.
In seconds too. That's awesome. Yeah.
No, literally like this run 100 million
that would be
like I mean that could be like too long
to do overnight before. Like there have
legitimately been times where it's like
That would be like a 30 40 hour training
experiment back in my PhD.
Yeah, that that's rough. I I believe it
though.
Okay. So, is it randomizing it like once
per end or something?
Should be per episode. Different
different start. not getting randomized
per episode, it looks like.
Oh, no, it is. It's just the animation's
not updating.
Yep. I think it's I think it's
If you go
to I've got a quick fix. Um, if you just
render them at their current position
and like cut out that
lurp, I think it'll work.
You won't get the smooth animation, but
you'll actually see where where it is.
At least just pause.
You could also set progress to one and
that might work
too. If this because I think progress is
staying at
zero. That could be part of the problem.
I like having the Pac-Man with the
puffer. the Pac-Man.
invalid from vector 2 to I vector 2. Oh
man. Oh yeah, that's rough.
I vector two. might be the the simplest
thing is just set progress to one like
see that float
progress. I think that'll also
effectively stop lurping if progress is
one.
puff. There he is. Oh no. Wait. Did he
just go through the wall? Uh, I don't
think he's supposed to do
that. Well, I think the lurp stuff is
still wrong.
it's like it's not
lurping the one axis like it's one of
the
coordinates. It looked like he was doing
like y axis but not x
axis. Oh,
did I miss one?
It it just
like displays the
position in between the their last
location and their current
location based on the progress like the
percentage of
time. Um yeah, I would just do it, man.
And I would just do it like pick a
number of frames per
step. Just do it fixed. Let me see if I
can get that working for you real quick.
Yeah, I think maybe if you set it to one
there that would work. I think I can do
Um, hang on. I've done this twice this
week.
Well, this kind of this kind of requires
you to do
Oh, I think I see the other issue
though.
Um, because it's updating the previous
alert
position outside of the render function.
That's the problem.
could you might be able to do like if
frame equals zero call the update lurp
position like I think that I think
that's
happening in the top level
loop for the
lurp this thing. Yeah, update
interpolation. I can I can definitely
fix all this stuff. Um,
see I want to see the thing go.
I I see that I see I've done it in a a
bad way. Now,
I would look at like the way that we do
it in uh in MOA or in um neural MMO is
neural MMO has tile based like
animations. Can I just do this? Does
this work? I think if you do that,
you'll definitely see it. Like it might
not interpolate, but they'll be in the
right
places, which would I think that's good
enough.
Hey, buffer.
Nice.
Yeah, he's trying, but it's freaking
hard when they don't slow down. Mhm.
I mean like actually what do you do
right?
Like okay like like what do I do here
Now they're coming for me.
Yeah, I think you're done.
Yep. I can't even [ __ ] eat any of
them.
Like I can get a bunch of points here
probably,
but solving it is tough. Yeah, I agree.
It's probably too
hard or impossible sometimes. Although I
think if it's impossible probably
depends on I got 170. That was my best.
Yeah,
but my best was about what the bot got.
I I don't have a proof that it's not
impossible. It might literally be
impossible. Probably dependent on
starting position though, if that's the
case and ghost delays and all that.
It's reliant. I think the the game is
reliant on you being able to bait them
to the power
here. Yeah, that's not it.
Maybe. Oh my god, that's so loud.
[Music]
I don't know how you mute the tab. What
the
Atari version of Pac-Man was kind of
the Atari version of Pac-Man was kind of garbage.
garbage.
A lot of them are. Oh, technically we
could we probably have that, right?
There probably is like a play mode that
I have built in already that I just
haven't bothered with like
But the arcade the arcade rules were
better. And then for Atari, Miss Pac-Man
was but like more like the arcade
rules. Ms there's just Pac-Man. Wait,
can I just do
Ah, darn. It doesn't render through uh
through the
Docker. I do literally have uh the Atari
version here,
but Oh, and it crashed my terminal. Good
job.
Let me push these fixes for you. And
then I got to go back to my lucrative
career of being a fashion model, I
guess.
All right, there you go. So, we have
Yeah, thanks. I mean, yeah, we got your
M training. There used to be all sorts
of stuff I had to show people with like,
you know, running sweeps and like tuning
this and tuning that and then we kind of
just I kind of just like added a better
algorithm and now it like the thing just
works. Nice. It's awesome.
That was fun. Very cool. So, I think you
I think you know um if you can make the
ghost look, I don't want to make you
spend tons and tons of time on this Z
because you sound like you're pretty
busy. And there's also if you want to do
RL stuff, there's also tons of other
stuff that you can do in here with
different M's and like, you know, I want
to keep stuff interesting. So, if you
want to do a bigger refactor, do a
bigger refactor. You want to do
different RL, do different RL. But for
this M, if you can at least just like
get the interpolation that you already
have to work and um maybe like I don't
know if you can make the ghost be slower
or like
something, but they've got to be nerfed
somehow while they're
um in power pill like when you get the
power pill so that you can actually eat
them. Cuz otherwise I think that the
whole point of
Pac-Man is that you're supposed to be
able to like eat a bunch of stuff and
then bait them to the power pill, right?
Yeah. Yeah, totally. No. Isn't that
That's how it works, right? Like if you
like
No, you I want to get the actual game
because I haven't like played it.
Why are they all so
loud? Okay, I can mute it.
Okay. Is it just Are the ghosts your
same speed?
They're a little faster,
but I think it depends on the level
you're on.
Look at that. So, it pauses. I eat
freaking three of them,
that. And I'm dead. But I also You get
five lives to complete this one level
usually. Mhm.
I'm sure you would get it if I had
multiple lives, too. Doing it on one
life with fast scared ghosts is is uh is
a lot
harder. Okay, so I just got the first
stage with two lives, right? after
having tried it several times on the
other
version and then it's like is it this
does the level ever get harder or is it
just you do the same damn thing
repeatedly?
It does get harder. Um how
the they stay frightened for less
time and they spend more time chasing
you and less time in their
corners. And then eventually the power
pills I think don't do anything which is
where it's like late game
and it's still solvable under that those
rules is interesting.
It is but I but I think human players
will memorize routes like there's
specific
strategies like a specific path you
take to beat the later levels.
There's a I
don't I don't think people are just
like playing like level 60 Pac-Man
without knowing like exactly what
they're doing.
I mean, you could pretty easily just add
lives as well. It's like you literally
already have the reset function broken
out for it. Mhm.
It's actually like mechanically kind of
snappy.
this, huh? Oh, it just gives you this
weird animation.
Why does it feel easier here? It's like,
is the ghost
AI different? It feels like more of the
ghosts just don't care about
me. You said the AI is the same.
It is. The timing might be
different. I'm not sure if I got that
right. Like how long they stay in there.
So, they're definitely like in the
corners there. Oh, and it like frame
perfects me.
Great. All right,
cool. All right. Well, congratulations
uh on your first NPR. If you can clean
up a few things, I think that'll be a
very nice uh addition. We like to have
some of these these classic arcade
games. Let's see how it looks at the
moment. I actually wasn't really even
paying attention to how it looks. I was
just kind of like trying to get it
solved. Do one very small
thing. Well, can I do you mind if I uh I
tweak the base pallet just a tiny bit?
Leave the ghost. Yeah, go for it.
Totally. You can you can tweak anything.
It's your project. Well, I like to be
somewhat respectful, you know, to the
contributors. But what we do like to do
is
We have a pallet kind and I draw things
from this. Gotcha.
Like
here. Let's just put this somewhere.
There should be a pellet color that you
could swap out.
I think it's called pallet color.
Oh yeah, we can do all of
colors
pro
rectangle. Okay. So this is the dot
color is right now.
Dots are yellowish. They're
rectangles. Okay, let's
try
color puff
white and the power
tile
red. And then let's
tiles? Tiles that are those are from a
tile set. Oh, okay. So those are fixed
color. They are. Yeah.
Fine. Your reprieve on the cyan tile
set.
eh it doesn't look good because the
tiles have the black in
them. Think
that's fix the wall tiles.
Hey, Plasma. Yeah, I
think I think it could actually look
really cool if we just I don't have um
is it one? It's one tile set image
actually, right?
Yeah, it's one. So, you could do like a
fill.
Go get
this. We're doing some puffer modding.
Uh, plasma.
I'm trying to get my end my my policy to
actually train correctly.
Uh, but it's no. Well, we might be able
to de we've debugged one env so far
today. I can also give you the uh if you
open the the the guide env. We've got uh
lots of things.
Yeah, you made a new tutorial env. Yeah,
trying to make things easier. It's
tough.
Yeah. In the config, do you need to tell
it specifically like the goal? Is it to
like maximize or minimize the reward or
you don't need that except for sweeps?
Ah, so for sweeps you do need it
cuz Okay.
All right. So here's to what is with the
lines on this thing? The lines it's only
used outside the lines, I guess.
Yeah, the the lines are never sampled.
They're not necessary, but you would
have to
change the some of the
calculations if we took the lines
Ah, I forget that the web version of
Photoshop sucks.
This is the one thing I miss. This is
the one thing I miss about about Windows
is having actual desktop Photoshop is
really
nice. The one and only bloody thing cuz
their web tool suck.
Just use [ __ ] dude. It's all so bad.
Where's the Where's the freaking wand
tool?
one tool in I like I know where this
stuff is and the but the like the web
version sucks like supposed to be a wand
tool on here that like I can just select
black pixels.
I can't. I literally This is unusable. I
don't know why I pay for this thing cuz
it sucks. The worthless software.
I mean, yeah, you missed a little
getting that Mhm. patience out of
I think we lost a corner there.
Here. Yeah. Where? Oh, it's the bottom.
Yeah. Literally can't cancel the
selection.
laugh.
Yeah, they're just they're
to just sucks. All right. I don't know
what to tell you.
like selecting the purple for no reason.
Yeah, that's really
This makesense. I think it's if you get
rid of the purple. I don't think there's
any downside to that. Like it's not
used.
like
crazy how bad this software has
gotten. Like every day we spray further
from whatever
He you're you start sounding like
Jonathan Blow.
Yeah. Usually has good software
takes and they're kind of obvious
software takes at this point though.
Like I don't know. I've gotten to the
point where it's like it's all kind of
obvious and it's just
like it's like I spend more time
cleaning up like external problems of
like random [ __ ] I spend fixing my own
problems.
Uh Python setup tools [ __ ] Python
devs. I swear they're all [ __ ] and none
of them can code. Not a single one can
code. All right.
And it's like I say this having
literally written Python for 10 years
and it's like
a I
disagree. Let's see. You want me to
review your code,
West? You want your code reviewed?
I'm not exactly
charitable. These hands are rated E for
backhand. All right, we're going to just
do the uh it's it's so crazy to me that
this is it's literally easier to
do rectangular marquet. Look, it's
amazing. I can select the pixels I want
manually and it's literally faster.
Wait, can I just do this? Oh, I think
you you you deleted one of the corners
there. Wait, did I? Oh, yeah. No. Yeah,
right. The the bottom left. Yeah. Was it
Was there a corner there? There was.
Damn it. It's the same as all the We'll
just draw it back. Can we draw it back?
Oh my god.
You could just take one of the other
corners and rotate it. And it's Yeah, I
don't know how to do that. So, we're
just going to do it this way.
Wait, that the brush doesn't [ __ ]
work. Just use the generative AI fill.
Okay. I don't know.
I'm just vibe drop. It literally says,
"What do you want to generate?" It
doesn't like It's not content aware or
anything. It's just like Yeah. No, no,
no. It's as dumb as they get.
telling you game fuel would have already
been done. It tries to paste.
I don't know, man. It's I mean, we could
add some smoke to this. That That could
be kind of cool.
I have brush
hardness. What is that G there? Yeah,
now we have text on the tile map.
What?
Damn it.
Photoshop. Somebody's going to just have
to do this, I think. And
Can I just
like there even a bucket
tool? Where the [ __ ] is the bucket tool?
I think they removed that one, too. Oh,
no. Here it is. So, like
So, it's What is it? Um
selection?
Okay. So, they kept the shortcuts the
same at least.
But like I can just
do
this. I wouldn't even worry about the
stuff in between. You can go over that.
Like that's just a visual
guide. I don't know why the [ __ ] I'm
doing this in the first place.
up that's not used. No, actually it
might be. I
forget. I think that is that part is
used.
You might be able to use the bucket tool
even if it's not
it. Like give me like ghost
fill is
[ __ ] Surely the most efficient way
is to select pixels one at a time in the
[ __ ] web version of Photoshop.
It's actually editing the binary
manually. That's that's the most
efficient. You know, it wouldn't be that
much slower at this point.
one. Yeah.
No,
this
think. Oh, man. I'm going to have to
copy the last one, I
Almost. Can I get it?
Nice.
Now that background
um transparent.
Uh what about the one at the bottom
left? Is that transparent too or am I
Yeah, I think
so. Yeah, I mean looks like
Let's see if this actually does anything
after all that.
Oh, that's looks like Puffer Pac-Man to
me. Nice.
I'm actually proud of that. That looks
like it. Yeah, I'm actually proud of
that. That's good.
Very
cool. Just need to get the
intribulations working the right way.
Right. Yeah. I can't get you interps.
But I did
uh I think that's pretty solid.
Mhm. Yeah, I'm happy with that.
There you
are. So I contributed
uh we also add the uh other colors the
background color.
We like to try to keep everything just
slightly puffer themed.
Nice. And uh yeah, that'll be cool. So,
I think if you fix the interpolation and
you do it without timing, if you do it
like based on frame or whatever, it will
also be able to just be way easier to
toss on the website. Sweet. Cuz I what I
would like to do, my goal is I would
like to have everybody as new MS. I
don't know what the heck happened here.
Oh, no. This is fine. It's just that
there are only a few tiles left. Um, I
want to have everybody's M on here. I
think by current count, we should have
22 environments for the release. Nice.
Nice be. Uh, it should be good. Hey, we
have nine people online. Welcome
everyone. This is uh open source ultra
hyper reinforcement learning stuff.
um build some environments with
us. What time is it? Nine.
I still have to launch a couple
quicks.
Uh this this other new one I think is
also going to be really nice. This
um
target I want to do way more with stuff
that looks like this. Oh yeah, also the
the C doesn't work perfectly. This is
supposed to be the policy loaded into C.
and it like kind of works, but I think
that there's like some there's some
small
errors because the the PyTorch version
is way better.
Are there any numerical precision
differences between torch and C? There's
probably I screwed or that or I screwed
something else up, right?
Um, yeah, I screwed I just screwed
something up for sure.
All right, I think I'm going to hop off,
but thank you very much for the you get
those things in. That'll be uh that'll
be great. And I will be very happy to
have Pac-Man in Puffer. Sweet. Thank
you. All right, have a good one. Yeah.
See you.
Let me get this. Let me make sure I can
actually run this thing plasma and then
uh we will take a look at
I'm going to keep watching this on the
side and let's take a quick look at your
end. Sure.
Um, basically, um, what I'm trying to do
is I turned on only the reward for like
I made it so that, uh, you can adjust
the reward parameters
um here. So, these are the reward
parameters. you're streaming. Hang on.
Let me let me Y
you're on.
I hope so. Basically, um I have these
tun tunable parameters. And right now,
um basically I only turned on the one
that discourages it from going into the
corners. And for some reason like most
policies I train basically like every
one of them love the quarter and I also
like switch to recurrent because it
works now.
Okay. Um I mean if you if you PR like an
initial version I can just like fiddle
with it. I can see um here I think I
pushed Yeah. Everything Wait, let me
Is it Syon or binding?
Uh, normal. The C binding, the new one.
That's nice. That's less work for me.
Mhm. I've done enough work. Lord
knows.
Okay, it should be up on
my Let me make sure. I think should be
up on my draft.
Good. Yeah, it should be Yeah, it should
be good now. You know, if you look at my
uh like in progress. Yeah, take your
time.
this one.
Uh, voids in in progress. That one.
Yeah,
voids.
First of all, let's actually look at
your
code. New PRS
I can't get the ramp to work. And that's
not
yeah. Oh, I know how we're going to fix
this for
sure. Okay.
Yeah, for
sure. Okay. Oh, should I copy that? No,
you're fine. Let me
just have 30. Okay. 300 line files.
Really, really pretty.
Yeah, a lot of it is just constants,
strcts. Yeah, you should take a look at
the new target code as well as a
reference. I made it really clean.
Yeah, I still have some like stuff I
probably should just like remove or
something like that. But you're like the
thing is it's going to always be worse
when you're like deving and confused on
how to get the thing to train. Like let
me help you with that and then you can
clean it up. I would like to have I
would like to have this one clean
because I actually want to do more
particle based stuff and this like Mhm.
really nice reference.
Yeah, particle base will be really cool.
It'll be really cool to do a lot with
that. what you did with the target but
for continuous which I'm guessing that
one looked it is it looked uh the
actions aren't continuous but the only
reason the action the actions are
discretized
um but the the state is continuous
by state what do you mean the position
the positions
yeah I see well I guess the actions cuz
it looked like the actions were very you
know They weren't very smooth. The only
reason that they're discretized is
because uh we have continuous actions.
They seem way way worse to train.
Yeah, I have continuous actions.
Oh, we're going to Yeah, that's
why. Why don't I just merge this, fix
it, and then I'll give you a full code
review when you're ready to actually
submit the code. Okay.
Um, is that okay? What What do you mean?
Like Oh, like you want to like So I Why
don't I help you? Why don't Why don't I
spend the time getting this to train
with you tonight? So I'll merge it and
then when you're ready to like have the
final version, I'll do a full code
review for you. Oh, okay. So like So
everyone review I do a full code review
for everyone when they submit an end.
But what I'm saying is that I'll still
do that, but why don't I just help you
get it to work for now? Yeah. Yeah, that
sounds
go. Just like that, we've got two new
M's.
Mhm. Well, not working yet, though.
[Music]
You happen to dev on a Mac that doesn't
have address sanitizer? Uh, no. I'm on
Linux right now.
And by that Wait, wait. Do you did you
uh just use the puffer? Um, train. No,
just the C script. Ah, okay. Well, the
Ccript actually worked on my Mac, but
maybe Well, I haven't tried it on here.
Let me see.
Well, if I compile it fast
scripts. So, it works in fast mode, but
you do have a memory. You have a memory
error. Okay, I need to then fix that.
voids
local add log unused function I don't
have ad log
oh I do current
index
cool let me
see oh yep I'm getting it now too let me
see
uh
Uh these
observations these observations are
wrong. Oh no, hang
on
times. Oh well, here it
is. I found
it.
Uh yeah, change that to Yep, that that
was probably
[Music]
the
overflow. Yeah, you can remove that ad
lock, too. I'm not using that
one. I don't know why I
didn't. Yeah, remove
that. Just nothing in it. Yeah.
Oh, okay. So, this is exactly what I
expected.
Um, watch this. Kale.
Kale. You mean a proc KL? It blew up for
a second and then then it actually
didn't. But you're on a zero score then.
Well, yeah. Yeah. Um,
so only only what's gets logged right
now for the user is N and score because
I have no idea what the others actually
mean like what should what I should do
with them. So I just am zeroing them
now. Okay. So can I let me mess with
some stuff here. So action space size
it's two. And then what is the what are
the actions supposed to be between
between zero and one or something?
Um it's between like negative one and
one or something. Okay. And then what
does it represent? Is it like vx v y or
something? Yeah, exactly. Okay. Easy. So
then all we have to do for that
So, what did you do next? Did you make
the actions? I just discretized I just
discretized the actions.
Um, but you're not getting any. I still
wasn't able to train. Uh
well score basically score right now the
user log score is average reward of all
the voids.
and not that, right? Yeah, that's the
exact opposite of what it should do.
Yeah, because um right now if you kept
the config the same, I basically only
turned on the corners. So basically the
way this agent gets negative reward is
by going to to like to the corners.
Oh, what is the observations?
Uh, the observations are the x y vx vy.
Oh, that'sed.
Oh, really? Yes, absolutely.
Okay, good point. And what is it? Is it
like size? Is the map size there? Like
map size? Yes, there is a width and
height.
It's in the client. Is it in the end?
I don't think so. No. How do you how do
you do do bounce detection in the end?
In the
end. Um in the step I
have. Yeah. Well, that's the thing. The
right here, right? This is a capital
width. Yep. It's the It's the constants.
Fine. All right. So, we'll do Yeah, I
should I can It's probably better. I
should probably have width and height.
Velocity. Uh, yes. Uh, I think it's
called a velocity cap. Exactly.
Right now, it's three, but again,
we can do that.
We're going to see if I can magically
solve all your problems today. Mhm.
I'm usually quite decent at that.
So what's um why I guess what's the
logic behind
um I guess um normalizing observations
neural nets don't like
is it that's seriously it neural nets
don't like big numbers right so you
normalize it just because it goes into
the neural net as an input and I guess
if it was just, you know, for the like
uh just for the env logic or the uh it
doesn't matter exactly. Okay. Yeah,
that looks different, doesn't it? That
looks really good. That's very different
from what you've had, huh? 100%. Okay,
so you only two fixes.
So you normalized observations, right?
And I discret and I discretized your
actions though. We can try it with uh
continuous but from my initial like my
tests on other environments continuous
has looked not so good.
Can we just try it and see how it looks?
We
can. But yeah, that looks good. That
looks really good.
Well, and I guess what do you think then
of I guess so is there a plan to make
continuous actions good? Well, I the
thing is I don't necessarily know it's a
bug and puffer. It could just be that
it's [ __ ] hard to learn.
H Are there any research papers do
talking about discrete versus continuous
actions? Well, we kind of know that
continuous is a total mess and uh this
is a good chance that this is why. And I
also know that there are researchers who
prefer not using continuous. That said,
this looks like it's learned just fine
in this case. Well, yeah. Let's see.
Let's see. This has learned uh just fine
with I believe this continuous. The
score looks good. This is totally fine.
So,
um let's let's see the eval of it
maybe. I mean, it's really on like
longer runs what happens. It's just very
unstable what I've seen.
Okay. Let's see. Okay. Yeah, they're
Yes. Okay.
So, it is working. They're vibing. Yeah.
Nice. It was literally just your data,
norm. I should add that. Yeah. It was
just my observations. Yeah. Let me just
do that real quick.
Yeah. Okay. That that that makes sense.
That totally makes sense. I for I
totally forgot about observation
there? Oh, no. Oh, this is the new guide
I'm writing. Oh, I thought I thought you
had it in there and you were going to be
like, just read the docs, please. You
know, read the damn manual.
Oh, actually I did add it to the recent
one. Oh, I do have it here. I actually
already had it in the the new the new
guide. Oh,
but this isn't pushed yet. Normalize. I
did actually write that as part of the
checklist. Mhm. There you go. I'm
predicting I'm predicting your errors.
Yeah. Um I guess now let's turn on all
the Yeah. How do I do it? Is it just in
the config? It's in in it's just in the
in
file. Yeah. I I made it so that we can
sweep them later. So these factors can
put them to whatever you want. Yeah.
Well, they don't like that.
What? Oh, we'll see. We'll see. It's a
lot more. Ah, actually, yeah, your your
your normalization your reward
normalization is off now. So, yes, it's
not going to work. Is the reward off?
Uh, yeah, now it is cuz um it's not
dynamically normalized. It just, you
know, I just divided by two in uh that
case. So, you can four. That's fine. Oh,
but look to nan.
um the other rewards
are more than four. They're like, yeah,
you probably we clip.
You shouldn't be able to break our uh
our train that easily.
Okay. Well, we we'll try a few different
things. I'll show
you to just do some experiment food
today.
Mhm. All right. So, this is no good.
Yeah. Says them's not the puffers.
Yeah. They're not puffering. Them not
the puffers, you know. Uh, so this avoid
one's probably pretty easy.
Yeah, that just means they should be
just running away from each other
scared like they seen a demon
is max zero.
Yes, that's that. Yeah, with this one.
Yes. The only uh one I add to is the
um
the margins reward. I'm thinking like I
was going through this and thinking of
how I can add it so that I just don't I
don't just p penalize I also
incentivize.
Whoa. Okay. They don't seem to be
avoiding each other. So that reward
doesn't seem to be I wouldn't expect
that to be zero.
They're puffering.
Well, kind of. Yeah. Um
So that one is kind of very simple. I
just
um I just basically calculate
how if they're in the protected zone,
how how far away they are from the um
void, like how close they are to the
edge of the protected zone. and I kind
of um Oh, that's not avoiding. Okay, so
that's
just what's
um Okay, we have to actually figure out
what are what are some intuitive ones
that we like know what it should do. Um
I mean, yeah, pro um protected one is
pretty intuitive in the sense of like um
this is avoiding the edge, I guess,
right? No. Uh so so the margin is the
one that avoids the edge. The avoid
factor avoids each other. They like try
to avoid each. Okay. They're not doing
that, right? Yes. That's the issue. Um
so h so right now I'm only penalizing
them based on if they are in the
protected zone or not. What's the
protected zone?
Uh it's you see how you have the
um so the reward is calculated in the
number is less than protected range.
It's just the number of voids that are
two plus. Okay. So here this is what
we'll do.
It's yeah but it I'm also calculating
I'm calculating how close they are to
the edge and the closer they are the
less penalized. They can't see each
other right? Or can they can they see
each other? They can't see each other.
Well, what do you Well, they do. I mean,
they kind of the the policy sees all of
them and No, it doesn't.
They the policy sees the observations of
Oh, you're
saying Are you saying that? Okay. Maybe
literally they can't see each other.
So is the observations array just means
that the um it's not just one policy.
It's not just like one input to one
policy. It's each one of those
xyvx y.
So this here so this voids index this
data here is what the first void will
see.
And then on index one that's what the
second void will see.
I see. Okay, that's not what I had in
mind. What I had in mind is to basically
have one network seeing everything and
managing everything. Well, you can do
that.
Would that just mean I just basically
flatten the array? Well, what you would
do here? No, you'd need to do you need
to do another loop. Um,
Okay. Ward is affected by their puffers.
Observations need to be and are not
yet. This is what we're do.
Well, they just I don't think see each
other
like they second they don't observe each
other but now hopefully they
do. The reward though is affected by the
other puffers because the reward is
basically calculating for each puffer.
It's looking at all the other puffers
and calculating the
reward. This might be hard for her to
learn. We will see.
There's the first pass. Now we have to
actually
um do like
obsess. I can Oh yeah, you need to muck
it correctly. I guess I can do.
Okay, we do this.
Yeah. And then you do the same thing
when you well I guess we don't need to
we don't need to allocate them because
we're passing them from the Python. So
we're fix to see after. I just want I
just want to I want to get you something
that actually works. Mhm.
the other thing is the the score doesn't
seem to be computed well.
reward. So that's yeah you have the
current reward for each step for each
like
um iteration and then the
Okay. In pixels, isn't it? Uh, yes.
Yeah. Two is nothing.
Okay. Yeah. Here we go. I don't know if
it's rain. Mhm. We'll see. And we can
probably, you
know, we can um That's going to be hard.
Maybe we can increase the screen range
and then have them like the screen size.
Oh, there's so much stuff we so much
stuff we can do here, man. you
know. Oh, and those margin turn factor,
centering factor, all those stuff you
can delete because we're uh getting them
from the config. So all those uh define
factors, pound define factors, you can
totally remove
the factors. Oh, okay. So that the
define margin turn factor that one you
you can remove all those because they're
gotten from the you know from the avoids
in
is everything is just moving too slow.
What do you mean?
It's really hard to learn if it takes a
million frames to do anything. Ah, so
you're saying
Yes. So, there you go. See, immediately
I just made it learn better by just
making everything go faster.
And you mean by like the voids having
the control to go faster.
So, let's see what this looks like. Then
you can probably remove the cap. Like
you can increase the caps. I did. Oh,
you
did? Oh,
see. Whoa. Whoa. Okay. Cool. Right.
Yeah. They're they're trying to avoid
each other. I can kind of see
that. Yeah. Damn. They're going fast
though. That's kind of It's cool, right?
Um Yeah. It just It's very chaotic.
Yeah, it's cool. Um
you pass these heights in. You don't,
right? Oh, yeah. I can make them uh
configurable. You don't have to. I just
wanted to.
It's cuz you don't want to have to build
over and over, you know? That's uh the
power of having a lot of these variables
configurable like in the Well, this is
just my build system's just stupid. It
should literally take 4 seconds. It
should take like 3 seconds to build.
Right now, you just have a lot of you're
just building a lot of environments.
Yeah, you should just be able to build
the one. Mhm.
like make it so that it's it's kind of
like make where if nothing changed,
don't compile it. That should just be CC
cache.
Yeah.
Um, if you want to look at the hang on
this is
by Hang Hang on. How does this make
sense?
Um, it's just the average. It's just So
the average since I'm only
uh Wait. Yeah. Let me looks wrong. Let
me try something. Right. No, no, no. You
can remove
the the absolute value.
What? Huh? No. So, so the protected
distance sum is like
it's it's a little more complicated than
just who is inside the protected range
versus who is not. It's not like a
binary. It's continuous. I made it so
that I see.
Yeah. But like, yeah, because this is on
zero. Um,
so it's like if a lot of the voids are
in the protected range but are in the in
like the edges of it in the perimeter,
um, it won't,
I guess, but this doesn't
like punish you as much.
So, if that makes sense. like like
the farther away a boy is from its uh
from its basically the closer one um
another boy is to the current void the
higher the punishment the further away
it is from the from it but it's it can
still be in the protected range um of
course it's going to get um punished
less I'm confused why I have zero score
here from this
uh I don't know that's uh maybe you have
no protected count
which can see is the only way I don't
know it's probably going to be random I
think
oh yeah okay that's the opposite they're
all grouped up Yeah. So protected
count if disc is less than protected
range this gets incremented
wait well that that one yeah but this
sum is
I'm confused this should shouldn't this
be they should be getting negative a ton
of reward.
So, um I do Yes, I do punish them. If
you take a look at that, that's a minus
equal. Oh, well. Yeah, you can make it.
I'm trying it. Thank you. Yeah, you can
make it. Oh, it doesn't seem I'm seeing
zero score either way. Oh, is it just
not getting logged?
[Music]
Nope. It was logging before. I don't
know. No, I think
should be getting logged. I don't know.
Yeah, this is probably going to be the
same
Yep. Yeah. Okay. So then this this has
to be zero. this protected count.
Uh yeah, I think you're just prot I
think the range is just not high enough.
Maybe your range is I set your range to
50.
Okay.
Ah yeah.
Oh okay. I think I know why. So you know
well
um
the well so you know how kind of each
void
the the point of it the x of and y of it
is not in the center it's in the top
left. Um, that might
be h that might be a reason, but I don't
know. I Why
is I mean I can you can take manual
control over them during eval and you
can print the reward and see what it is,
but I have an idea.
Okay. I thought that would be it.
Yeah, I think you're just not getting
Did I really Did I rebuild it? I did.
Maybe not. You did.
Okay.
Um I mean
logging is broken. How is logging
broken? Bet.
Well, logging is broken because they're
all zeros. It's never all zeros usually.
Well, I don't think it's I think it's
the calc itself that's broken.
Well, yeah, it's not logging broken. I
made them all zeros besides score. Score
and n are the only ones I put stuff
into.
Yeah, that's confusing for now. Well,
those I can remove them. I just didn't
remove them. I was just in the middle of
things, you know.
It is confusing. But I'll quote myself.
The hardest part about making an
environment is getting it to actually
work.
I've I've gotten a few environments
working in the last day or so. Bet.
Yeah, I would I would hope so, Joseph.
Okay. No, there are protected count. Why
is it not?
That was more for plasma versus for you.
Yeah. Um, so the waste core gets
calculated is just
I bet you this avoid factor isn't
getting set.
I just start logging stuff at this
point.
Void factor. Just just printing printing
everything and you you'll find it. Yeah,
I I guarantee it.
from all the YouTube folks.
This is live RL debugging.
You too can do live RL debugging at 9:51
p.m. if you submit some interesting code
to Puffer Lip.
Yeah, I still got a long way to go with
these, but it takes time.
All right, so what I'm learning a lot.
Yeah, now score is still zero. So what
do you what do you do with score?
Score I just set it to the um reward
that is calculated on the three lines
above it. So the ends rewards current
index equals current void reward /
two and just set it to that.
And current void reward is what?
I see. It's
a complex calculation.
No, really. No, it's just average score
is just average. If that's what you're
talking about,
maybe we should print current void
reward. Oh, you have this as
uh some like dumb cast or some
ridiculous thing happening here is my
guess.
Oh, Numbboys is unsigned. So,
does that get promoted?
Still zero. I don't think Oh, wait. No,
there's the first zero now. Oh,
okay. So, that might have been it. The
plot thickens.
Yeah, that definitely is uh is telling.
It's something to do with current void
reward or with that particular cast.
if one of your logging things gets uh
gets re, you know, recast as something.
Okay, the score now is working. Let's
see if it learns.
And this is continuous actions, right?
No, I have it on discrete.
Okay.
So that I uh I checked the cart pole. So
with your args, it still trains. It's
not that I broke continuous actions.
It's just that they've always been worse
than discreet. And because of the new
optimizer changes, our new optimizer
like is able to get really aggressive
hyperparams for discrete and
multi-discreet, but for whatever reason,
you can't for continuous.
Oh, okay. It's more subtle than just I
screwed something up, I think. Okay,
good to know. The the the main issue
with continuous was that that we would
just hit hard torch
errors. That was No, I fixed that. It's
it's numerically unstable. Okay. Well,
yeah, thank you for telling me before
I instead instead of uh saying, "Oh,
yeah. Yeah, it's fixed, but knowing
secretly that it's probably not going to
work." So, does it does it work with
like Adam or something?
Uh I tried that and no I still couldn't
get it to work with our aggressive
parameters with very very like cartpole
stable enough to solve it in continuous
you can solve uh if you just take muon
and lower the learning rate it'll be
stable for long enough to solve it but
it will eventually explode. Um and I've
seen that pretty consistently across
everything.
Oh interesting exploding
bad. Uh oh that's because it it worked
really well before. No it didn't. I uh I
checked your thing and it was just
because of your params. Like if you set
more aggressive params, it doesn't.
No. Okay, that looks well. They're doing
something. Yeah. Uh yeah. Yeah, that
looks about right. The puffer sim.
There you go. They're This kind of like
uh reminds you of bingo almost. They
like to like to puff around. You pick a
puffer. Pick a puffer. Any puffer puff
63. Puff 63
now.
Okay. Maybe can you try it with this
reward doesn't make sense to me still?
It's like the magnitude off. Oh, okay.
So, well, I can kind of explain this or
anything like
the rewards. Is it normalized? Cuz like
this thing is like if I just take this
protected count, this should be
divided by two. That's normal. I mean,
there should be a lot of there should be
a lot of puffers up in your grill,
right? Like why why is it so low?
What is this? What? This is all puffers
within I maybe this is just too
low. 100.
So let's see how let's see how many we
if we have a 100 puffers.
Oh yeah.
There's just no way. Like I've gotten
really cool results with this type of a
thing before with my grid M. Like I've
gotten grid M's where all the agents
like perfectly spread
out. Can do it.
Well, remember it's only negatives. I'm
only giving it punishments. There's
no at least for this specific uh check
my
calculation. But then this should be
like 60 or 32 I think.
Oh, good to CPR so I can yell at him.
Uh, that's
M00000. Doesn't train
yet. If you're reading that code as a
reference, I would highly suggest you
read Actually, why don't you go beta
test my new tutorial?
back? I was going to ask if there's
anything I can do to help with the
release, but I think I will do that
then. Sounds sounds like it's right up
my alley. I should be able to do that in
an hour, right? which the CPR beta
testing the new tutorial. Well, I mean,
it's just it's just basically reading it
and see if you like it. Um Oh, okay.
Yeah, I can definitely do that in an
hour. You just have to open You just
have to open the HTML is all
that. That's all right. I'm not afraid
of HTML.
You just have to load this somewhere.
All right, got it. Yeah, we'll do. Easy.
And the only It's only the environment
docs bet. The rest of it's not done, but
there's like an environment tutorial.
I'll only do I'll only critique the
stuff that's actually done.
Uh, did you uh did you merge the vector
fix that guy vector fix? I have not
merged that yet. I've only tested I've
only tested it with non uh nonpuffer MS,
but it works fine with non-puffer MS and
it does fix a uh it does fix a uh
it does fix a a puff up, if you will.
Got a puff up. Uh, I was able to re
reproduce the the puff up by changing
that guy's script. He's got he's got
that script. Do you have the script by
the way?
Yep. Yep. We can hear you. Okay. My mic
was broken. I fixed it again.
That
Oh, hey man. Okay. So, what did you need
me to do? Oh, I said I just If you're
looking for I mean, you've been trying
to make M lately, right? So, like if you
want to uh check out I like I made a
very nice tutorial for it basically
as part of the new dock. I'll get to
you. I mean you how does here how's this
look to you? Like how's this target M
look to you? You can learn to Well, I
guess this is it's better in PyTorch.
Hang on. Oh, that's Yeah, I saw that on
Yeah, I I think you've seen it on the
stream, right? You can learn to make
that environment though. It's like 200
lines of code.
Yeah. And it's nicely commented and
everything.
Comments very well. Oh yeah. Nice.
HTM. Yeah. And there's actually like
there's some commentary and stuff in the
it's just HTML for now, but the new dog
page,
you can get it on the the dev branch of
puffer the puffer.ai repo.
what I'm trying for why is this uh this
protected region is so like
ridiculous. Um
um I mean what
what what are you having a hard time
understanding?
Wait. Oh, I see it. I see it.
Yeah, this is indented wrong, man.
What? What? That's C though. Yeah, but
this is like that.
Oh, well, if it's missing a bracket,
that's different. Yeah.
I know. Kung fu.
What?
How did How did Well, I mean, I told you
guys about formatting.
You You just took it out of the for
loop.
Uh, wait. Maybe I'm wrong then.
You do have a I can't even see the
beginning of that. Maybe I'm wrong,
Joseph. I mean, maybe maybe the kung fu
is uh pull something impressive. You
cooked too much. You overcooked. Wait a
minute. Hang on. Look, I've been
cooking. I've been cooking all day. I
might have overcooked a little bit. All
right. I've been doing [ __ ] dumbass
debugging all day. All right.
We might have We might have overcooked a
little bit. It must be this guy. I can
tell you that there's a bug, but before
I can tell you what the bug is. Okay.
Well, so what what I guess are you
having trouble understanding this count
variable should be like this should be
64 like this score and it's not 64. Oh,
it's not 64 because not all
um voids are in the protected range. I
had this set to a th00and. I don't know
where it
went. Maybe I just didn't freaking
compile it.
Mhm. Yeah. Now it should be 64. You
arrive. Oh man, this is so stupid.
But we did get some like cool stuff with
the
Novoid. It's negative.4.
No, it should
be one because
right
it should well actually be like 32 cuz
you by two, right? Oh. Oh, right. Right.
Yeah. You have the normalization which
divides it by two. Uh and then you add
that 32 and then you all at on the end
divided by 32. Yeah. So it should be
-32 if you have it as like just
basically the current void reward like
for the protected stuff is just
protected count, right?
Where do you have it as? Yeah, you just
have protected
count. Oh. Um, so protected.
Yeah, that should
be. Okay. Why is it
418?
What? Update model. Wait.
You PR this? This isn't PR yet. This
voids
uh initial PR. Oh, that one.
Hey, this
is you
63.
Okay. Why is it 63?
All right. Yeah, it makes sense why it's
63. Okay.
Use in DX for index. That is maniacal.
Well, I don't know. For me, it makes
sense. But do you use IDX? You can't. I
N D. What is that? Or just like I What
are those? A guy.
What are those?
I can Yeah, that's fine. I can change it
to like idx or I if you want whatever
you want.
What happened? No, I use for index. I
use indx.
So you're telling me that that was not
an LLM? That was you. Your personal
choice. Yeah. Oh my god. I mean, I feel
like an LLM would just do I. Yeah. Oh,
it'll it'll do whatever. My guy. Oh,
this I didn't see this line right here.
Duh.
Oh, the averaging. Yeah, I didn't see
that line. That's why I've been confused
the last 15 minutes.
I've been writing code all day. Yeah.
All right. I've been writing code all
day. Dev's worst nightmare.
View file.
When I write the code, the code's
simple. It's clean. All right.
Whoa. Whoa. There's a video. That one is
not.
We don't talk about when it's not. We
don't talk about
that. Where am I? What did I do? How did
I get here? I'm I'm on the wrong
version.
I was looking at my version of the dev
br the dev branch from my fork instead
of yours for the last 10 minutes.
I'm an idiot. I don't understand. I I
literally DM'd you the HTML file.
I I I hadn't looked at that. That wasn't
what I was talking about. I hadn't I
haven't looked at it that yet, but All
right. This actually learned something
with really stupidly scaled rewards.
What did I do? Yeah. Yeah. You need I
There's no more minmax normalization
now. It's just division by whatever.
Probably going to look pretty similar.
Uh CPR pi script is
like anti- every single puffer format
standard. Yes. Fix that freaking end, my
guy.
There's only so much I can do without
literally rewriting everyone's code. All
right. I try to get I try to show I try
to show people the way. I try to lead
people to the simple code that doesn't
drive you insane.
I can only do so much.
You can lead the donkey to the well, but
you can't make it drink.
Oh, I I can make the donkey drink. I
just can't like prevent it from jumping
back in the You know what it feels like?
Where
Oh yeah, this this freaking thing. Oh
yeah, yeah, yeah. This is literally me
trying to help freaking researchers.
Okay,
that's what it feels like making tools
for researchers. All right, it's like,
oh, 5 million steps per second. Thonk,
five steps per second.
All right. That's what it feels like.
This is why I do a lot of my own stuff
these days. You get no appreciation
around there. Speaking of which, if you
appreciate the puffer, start the repo.
What are you doing? You're watching
this. Come on. Start the repo. It helps
us out. Start the puffer. It's free.
Start the puffer. The puffer eats stars.
We're at 20 45 stars. You should make it
so that the puffer gets bigger as more
stars. thinking about that.
I I think it's too small to notice
though, unfortunately at this time.
Yeah, it is.
Puffer.
Oh man, there's so many dumb things I
thought of to do with the puffer. But
it's just like it's waste of time
compared to doing any actual work. I've
been like, so what I could do is I could
foam cast some like some molds, right?
So you get like foam molds, right? And
then I use that. I paint that up and I
put it as a shell around a drone. Okay?
Okay. And then I just have to Yes, dude.
Run that on. Dude, imagine Boyd uh on
drones.
I
I'll be insane. We've just lost all of
our drones. Yeah, yourself.
We lost all of our drones.
What? What? We lose all our drones. No,
we we were saying like imagine if we ran
the voids on on drones. Oh, yeah. Well,
I mean I honestly I think we could
probably train some pretty ridiculously
impressive stuff very
easily. Just if you like literally if
they just knew the every knew each
other's positions and nothing else some
really crazy swarming stuff. Oh yeah,
this should be easier than whatever
weird
thing we're trying to implement.
Okay, so there you
go. The reward a little tiny bit.
Yeah, we probably need to normalize it
better probably. I don't know.
Am I missing something on this tutorial?
Is it clip? Is Do you have like an F
clip app training demo? Uh I don't uh I
have a clip thing for me. Yeah, I I
think I have a clip helper.
F
clip. L clip. Yeah, fell. I don't know
why
Fell crazy approximate like the crazy
variables.
Crazy.
What are you doing? Listen,
[Laughter]
ind we had like six different naming
conventions for steps and time. Well,
they weren't naming conventions. They
were just whatever people had used for
it. I know.
Yeah, we can make it just um Fclipip F.
We're going to do this. We're going to
train your model again. We're going to
do points and we're going to move on and
we're going to win.
Mhm.
And we have the puffer cyclone.
A puffer transformer.
Puffer cyclone.
There was actually there was actually a
tornado there was a hurricane the other
day. It turns out that tornado touched
down about 40 miles from here and killed
nine people. What? Yeah. Yeah. Uh-huh.
Are you in a tor really? There's
tornadoes.
I don't know. I was tempted to go
outside and to run in that store. It
looked fun.
Ah,
listen moment. Listen, your reward
function is
uh has some uh
better than your reward function.
True. I don't know. I like I like
running in storms. It's fun.
Isn't it too cold?
I ran marathons in Boston in the winter.
No, late. It's like late spring here in
the b like let me tell you like I would
go in like just on a random day like
before I went into the lab I'd go run
like a half around the river in uh in
Boston and it would be like freaking
dark like 7 a.m. 6:30 a.m. freezing rain
horizontal with like a light like a
light jumper maybe and like like you
know real thin sweats and that's it. And
uh yeah, I do that. I'd like get to
Duncan on the way back, get a hot coffee
and like four donuts and just like get a
hot shower and just like But before I
got my coffee and hot shower, it's like
I walk right through
you. This is not not a happy camper with
that.
That doesn't sound fun. Oh my god.
I got in good shape. I ran uh I ran one
marathon in Boston before Nice. I left
there. I had the one in Florida and then
I did my 50k in California.
Yeah, I miss California so much because
I just came back from vacation and I ran
like twice a day and now in New Jersey
I'm running like once a week. I need to
get some weights.
Oh yeah, I'm probably gonna get a plan
of fitness membership here next week.
But speaking of which, my avankos get
here tomorrow.
I get dumbbells. I got five through 50s
and I got 60, 70, 80s, 90s, and hundreds
coming. You have uh Did you also get I'm
guessing you also got the the dumbbell
uh shelves or whatever you want to call
racks
back
there. Uh, right behind my rack.
Oh, they're just in boxes. No, the shelf
doesn't have the d on them. I got the
Oh, I see him. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I see
him right next to the rack. Like right
behind the rack. Like the squat rack.
Okay, cool. I got the dead bar. I've got
the log. I've got the squad. I got my
bench. Other things. Why is the salmon
ladder on the other side?
What? It's switched.
What do you mean? Why is the same It's
always been on It's always been on the
left side. Now it's on the right side.
Is it? Wait. Yeah. You swap your But if
you swap your thing, why is the camera
No, the Cuz the camera I switched the
camera because I had to So the flag
shows the right way. Oh, is the flag the
other way before? The flag is The flag
is mounted the correct way, but
sometimes if it flips your camera, it'll
show wrong.
Huh. I might have to review some footage
here to to see camera mirror effect
thingy.
Good flag though. Makes sense.
Big flag. You got to have a flag for a
gem. I'll make the rules. That's true. I
agree. All right. What else? What else
did we get? What the what other rewards
are cool in here?
um the uh one of like matching uh
velocities and position like average
velocities and position. So there's the
centering factor which is average
position and matching factor which is
velocity.
Yeah. So like um the voids
um try to basically have the uh average
velocity of voids in its uh visual range
or whatever. But for now, yeah, you can
see everything. It just the reward only
um applies in a certain range.
That one is for the velocity. Yeah, the
matching
I learned a lot though building this and
I'm learning literally every time you
debug my stuff. I'm just like learning
so much. That's the goal.
Joseph, would you prefer things having
the same naming convention across C and
across Python or having Python and C
having different naming conventions
intentionally?
Depends on the thing. Yeah. What are you
talking about specifically? In in
Python, step is almost always referred
to as tick and time out is referred to
as timeout. Whereas in C in the header
files, uh, step is used or numbum steps
is used or a bunch of other things are
used for steps and, uh, time test is
used instead of timeout, but they both
do the same thing. We should probably
keep it the same, but I mean, that's
really pedantic. Honestly, I care so
much more about stuff like not having a
halfozen or like having a dozen
redundant functions and like stupid
extra abstractions than I care about
having the names always be the same.
Okay.
Like it's like if you're going to look
for something, if you're going to look
for like stuff that's wrong with the
M's, like triple triad was Spencer's
first M before I yelled at him a bunch
and like that's got like [ __ ]
quadruple pointers in it. They're like a
bunch of M's that have like three like
four like five strs when they need one
strruct and like a ton of like it's just
like overly abstracted [ __ ] And
like and to be fair, Spencer's like he's
kicking ass now with the M he's been
building. So it's just like yeah, people
learn this stuff. It's like I don't
know. I like I don't want I don't know
who the [ __ ] I give to the stuff to like
just a refactor because the thing is
like I don't want to give it to someone
who's more junior because like it's
actually something. It's not like oh
just let the LLM do it or whatever. It
actually no like writing good clean code
is one of the hardest things you can do.
But at the same time, if you're capable
of doing that, then you could probably
also be like making some more freaking
awesome
ends. Oh, it's tough. What? Wait, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa. Hold on. Why
the heck? Sorry, I just saw something.
Triple tread does not work right now.
So, if you want Yes, it does. Okay,
proof.
Hey, this is kind of cool.
It's this is the matching velocity
rewards.
Yeah, for me.
Okay. Well, I guess what should it do?
Theoretically, it should try just match
them. So, they kind of look like they're
doing that.
Yeah. Yeah, they are.
Yeah. You get some like It looks like
hurricanes. Here comes the hurricane.
Run in
that. Just run into the voids.
Yeah, it'll look cooler if you do not
match velocity.
Well, that's the thing. We're going to
have it's a tunable factor, so you can,
you know.
Oh, I see what's happened
here. Okay. Also, my steps per second
here seem
very low.
Oh, poor you. You only get to train at
1.5 million steps per second. Mhm. Dude,
look at look at how much the ends the
end is 2%.
It's like 2% too much. Yeah. Should be
it should be zero. Should take zero,
right? They're well you
tr experiment to see is when you turn on
the um reward of like the um avoid it
avoid
factor. You can so you can I I put in
the functionality that you can just like
press shift and they all flock into your
cursor wherever your cursor
is. So, um I wonder like Yeah, like
that. Like, yeah. What would happen if
you put a void factor, you know, like if
you put Well, they're they're kind of
doing that kind of now. Yeah. You can
literally Yeah.
[Laughter]
You're just You're just happy. I just
like Yeah. I'm not going to lie. Puffers
here. Have some puffers.
Yeah. They don't they don't collide with
each other. But I mean I think that's
the right call is to make them like be
able to go through each other. No, it's
the thing is like we got to tune do a
little
also. Um, so for the avoidance reward,
um, like my original, uh, avoidance
reward, I would like to try to explain
it to you and you may be telling me
like, is this a good idea? Is this bad?
And like why it's bad, why it's good or
kind of thing or like, well, I'm mostly
looking for why it's bad. Hang on. But
yeah, let me do
one. Mhm.
This gets like
six.
Okay. What the [ __ ] is this mini batch
size?
So what's gamma
discount factor? What's gamma
discount factor? Gamma is very
important. What does it tune? Does it
Okay, I guess yeah, I need to I need to
um look more into RL and like read some
papers, read some I have a blog for you.
Blog posts? Yeah, give me a blog post.
Is it my blog post? What's Costas? Well,
that is that is one of the ones I
recommend in my blog post. I'll give you
that. Okay, start with justice.
I also have a massive list of various
resources. So, if you want any, just DM
me. I'll DM you then. But also, I guess
um for prerequisites. Um, should I? Cuz
right now I'm kind of in the middle of
going through Carpathy has like this
zero to her ML stuff where he shows up
to makes good stuff. uh like he goes
through papers and stuff through like
the like he went through um the
um paper that explains
uh what it's called that explains uh how
to kind of proposes a solution to the
curse of dimensionality
um by like instead of instead of having
like bgrams or trigrams you you know you
just switch it to normal
that then kind of
represents like it basically compresses
all those biograms or uh the the matrix
the biogram matrix or the triagram
uh tensor or whatever you want to call
it um matrix it would be probably yeah
um it compresses it to just basically
having a neural
work and I think next is Alex net
but I don't
Okay, this looks good. One down.
This one's took me like 10 times
down. I finished formatting CPR
correctly. That one took like 10 N's
worth.
Wait, what are you doing to format it?
Uh, just normalizing variable names and
whatnot, right?
MBR stuff. As long as it's not broken.
HPR all that stuff. As long as it's not
Yeah, that's what I'm going to do at the
end. I'm basing everything basically off
of the way you formatted neural MMO 3
and Oh god, that's like one of the first
M though.
Yeah. Um, read read the target end. Read
the target end real quick. Okay, sure.
Because I wrote it yesterday, so it's
like the like cleanest
most up toate thing. Neural MMO is like
pretty decent, but it's also the first
major piece of C that I had to write.
So that's 2.0. What am I
doing? Okay, there we go.
material squared and target cleaned
up. Nice.
What? Making you a network.
Me boys
network. Okay. Oh,
congratulations. Get a network.
You get a You're like Oprah now. Giving
you a network. You get a network and you
get a network.
You get a network and you'll get a
network.
You scream, I scream. We all scream for
networks.
Oh my. Why does I I select the dev
branch and then I click from the dev
branch puffer liib into the dev branch
puffer lib ocean and it switches to 2.0
Now I just need the pencil.
Yep. Nice.
Okay.
Interesting. Outline
pencil pen. Just
nice. Nice. I got a puffer white board.
Sketchboard buffer themed
sketchboard. Yeah, it's basically the
same thing. Uh, in fact, your PIS script
is essentially basically how I'm
rewriting it with the um target SPS
being like the only main thing
different. And you also changed Yeah,
you you changed ticks to step as well.
So that's that's funny.
What What did I change to steps? Um,
yeah. So in I just do that in the perf
test cuz I I the reason I do that is cuz
like ticks is like when you're like in
the internals of the game, it's the
number of game ticks or whatever. Yeah.
So yeah, that's why I usually do that.
Yeah, a lot of the older M's have ticks
instead. Yeah, tick is fine. Steps is
fine. It doesn't matter that much.
Yeah, it depends because like the thing
is tick is like for a neural MMO
specifically like the tick system is a
common thing that you to talk about in
like an MMO.
Yep. It's also confusing steps is more
straightforward. That's fine.
I'm nitpicky.
Okay, here we go. Um, I can commit this
now. Oh, cuz I keep Oh, that's why cuz I
have two tabs open. That's probably why
it's defaulting to
2.0.
Okay, that's fixed. Okay.
Okay,
doing this. I'm going to bed. Okay,
hoping this does
something. Let's
see. Okay, what did he change in the
network? Oh.
glue. Oh, should be relu right now.
talking about.
Technically, I am increasing Perf, but
I'm increasing it by a absolutely
infinitely small
amount, but I can't
spell. Okay.
Okay. So, the new blog uh the new blog
post or tutorial you're going to create
is just called blog.html.
Oh, it's uh it's it's in the docs.html
docs. I see in that file.
go. What am I doing? I'm
done. Wrong file. I'm getting turned
around. That's smart of me.
paste observation.
Oh.
Oh, hello.
Do you want the Perf test for the Python
script to be in directly if name or do
you want it to be its own function?
Uh I put it in the main so that you can
run that the class directly. You can
just run the script.
see one of the first fundamental then
skip right to
rainbow. Ah okay. Yeah I need to
understand
that. Mhm.
interesting. Appealing as an impressive
result.
Ah, for some reason in target.py Pi you
have I and steps and they both function
as the same variable where in target.py
pi unless I'm blind but I controlled F
and I couldn't find any use for it where
steps wouldn't be in normally.
Steps get incremented by num agent so I
get to incremented by one.
Ah and it's I% cache. Gotcha.
I love your description of multi- aent
RL.
What? his his description of multi- aent
RL in his uh blog post is it's the same
as as single agent RL except uh that the
environments and tools are
jank. Oh, I see what's happened here in
the Okay.
well, this certainly is a good job of
slowing it the hell down.
Oh, uh, the new neural net. Yeah, there
we go. Okay. What what what are
architecture? Are you just doing a lot
of LSTMs or groups? Pointwise
architecture. So, it's it encodes all
the voids the same. So, it's
positionally independent.
Um, I don't
know if it doesn't Does it learn any
better? No idea. Probably not.
I think you got to like do some work on
like the dynamics of this thing. Like it
should be you should be able to get like
these nice swarm things out of it.
Yeah.
I'm going to give you I'm going to
commit all this stuff up to you. You
don't have to use this net. You can go
back to the default one. I'm gonna give
you all the stuff that I've done for
now. Yeah. Um, where are you going to
commit it?
Dev.
Okay,
sure. Okay, I simplified it out so I
isn't used anymore and used the old
version. I think that's it's it's more
easy to look at, at least in my opinion.
It removes an extra variable that you
don't need.
So, what would be I guess I was going to
make a reference to a very old cartoon
and then I realized that you weren't
alive for that.
You'd be surprised. I might have not
been alive, but I might have seen it. I
have no clue. My dad is a boomer, so I
have seen a lot of old stuff.
I'm a bunch of old
So, what should be kind of my next
steps? Is it just adjusting rewards or
you're going to have to I You're going
to have to adjust the rewards. You're
going to have to get [ __ ] normalized.
Um, right. Like RL's not going to
respond to like, well, if they're two
voids next to me, I get negative. two
reward, but if there three voids next to
me, I get negative03 reward.
Like you it's like you got to give it a
signal it can actually learn off of
which is why it's like all right one boy
near you's negative quarter, two boys is
negative a half, you know, whatever. I
got to cap the rules. So very simple
kind of just Yeah. very overthink it.
Mhm. And then like I I think that you
want to like look at the original the
original rules right from that end and
see if you can get
like it's probably like the alignment
and the dispersion that are the most
important right. Um yeah, the the
alignment and the um avoidance.
Well, is it is it just avoidance?
The [ __ ] There's a I don't know. I can
give you the Cornell the Cornell one.
Well, you can look it up. Just voids.
Cornell. Yeah, this thing. So, like
Well, separation.
Oh, but it's coherence, right? So it's
coherence coherence separation
alignment. Yeah, you need these. I I
have um
but yeah, I can I guess I mean I can
name them coherence separation. I don't
care the name. It's just you got to like
I there was a lot of normalization and
jank and weird things going on. So like
you got to get like you got to get these
in a way that they can be very
learnable. I think that like once you
get a nice clean version of this, it
should be very easy to just instantly
learn this type of behavior and it'll be
really cool to have. Okay. Yeah, it
might be that like here, look at this.
So, they have like this coherence.
Mhm. There's this separation.
This is the avoidance. Yeah. Like look
this. So, this is just like this is
random whatever.
Then you'd
like now they all want to just go in the
same direction. Yeah.
Now they want to stay away from each
other as
well. That's pretty freaking cool.
[Music]
Mm. Right. There's like so much cool
stuff. I mean, you can see it's a little
fiddly to like hit the original
behaviors. Like look
How's everyone doing? Good to
Yeah. Hey, man. Yep. Yep. I've been
fixing al I've been fixing freaking code
and fixing networks and fixing
everything.
Sounds like fun. Sounds like you guys
having a party.
I'm in the office just chugging like six
I'm on like six bottle of Red Bull. Oh
jeez. I've done that. I have a paper
deal in a few days. So
I get that done.
Yeah,
I'm going to die young.
I did that through all of undergrad, but
I stopped in grad
school. I don't know who this
is. Uh this he is in a bunch of the
random group chats I am in. And I highly
suspect it's like CCP spy.
It's some It's some random engineer girl
who has genetically beautiful in her
Twitter bio and like makes like vaguely
flirty comments with like all the random
engineers in these like that's like no
that's CCP spy. There's no way.
Oh god. I just realized what she meant.
They go by CPC now.
Is that so?
Yes. In order to be more friendly and
more uh what was the exact words they
used? They were trying to appear I I
guess less communist. I don't know what
makes sense.
It's it's instead of the Well, the funny
thing is China is not actually
communist, but that's a whole long
story. No, they're Marxist Leninist. I
think it's more fascist and they tell
the people who support it. They tell
everyone it's communist so that they
support them or whatever. That's
communism. Yeah. So CP CCP is the
Chinese Communist Party whereas CPC is
Communist Party of China. So it's
supposed to be more they've been that
way since they've been CPC officially
internally since like 2000 something.
But uh as we can see this is not the
communist. We have the American flag.
Yeah. America. America reminds me of
this guy that I was in a project with
and I think he called like football
soccer and I was like, "No, it's not
football. It's not soccer. It's
football." And then he says, "Bro, I I
bleed red, white, and blue." I was like,
"What the [ __ ] does that mean?" And
then, "Oh, the flag." I was like, "Oh,
okay."
That's funny.
Welcome. Most people just bleed red.
Yeah, but us, you know, Americans have
that uh blue 240 or whatever, you know,
so they bleed blue.
What does blue mean? All the dyes. It's
like the food dyes. Dies. Yeah. Oh,
right. We do. We have that in America.
All right. I gotta I gotta call it
though for the night. Call it for the
stream and everything. So, um, all
right, man. Take care. So, yeah, for the
folks that have been Yeah. I Can we get
all everybody to start the puffer? It
really helps when people
I mean, I've done it twice at least. All
right. It's true. All right. I will be
back tomorrow.
Uh, streaming RLdev all day except for
when I get my 1400 lb of dumbbells
delivered. I'm very much I'm very much
looking forward to Also, my server
should be here soon. Not. Yeah. The the
tiny boxes. It's like, you know, you
really I don't feel bad about buying
dumbbells and stuff when I think about
how much the damn servers cost.
Like, god damn, giving George all my
money. No, luckily those ones weren't
even with tariffs. You know, the
non-tariffs is still 25 grand a box. Um,
all right. And I I think most of it is
because uh they are all on kind of one
machine. So, that is not something
that's easy. There's not a crazy big
markup. They're actually they're pretty
good. Um, yeah, it's just the chips are
expensive. Nvidia's like, yeah. Anyways,
it's very simple. See you, Joseph. We
got we got a lot of stuff. So, there's
the new tutorial done today. There's the
new M's done today. There's the new
Pac-Man M integrated initial version.
We've got some progress on Boyds here.
Um, so I think that tomorrow, oh, I also
shipped the initial dev container. It's
on the Docker Hub at the moment. and I
got to slim it down and I got to make
some fixes to it. But I think that
probably tomorrow I'm going to start I'm
going to spend like a couple hours
finishing docks and then I'm going to
try to just like hammer out as many
experiments as I can. Uh cuz we need to
get to like the final experiments, final
ablations, put it all together. This
thing has just got to ship. The longer
this thing goes without shipping, the
crazier I'm going to go. So yeah, agree.
That's all. All right.